normalerweise wirklich gibt die
hinzugefügt werden auch wenn ich die
abfahrt
fakt ist was soll das denn da wäre ich
so safe bei gestorben
na ja wir haben hier mit gerade lucky
blogs mit einem command in minecraft
hinzugefügt
a
löw ich meine lieben freunde ich habe
gerade schon auf name aufgenommen aber
vergessen auf den aufnahmeknopf drücken
ich weiß ich bin ein verkappter kaka
spaß in der tat heute ist freitag in der
tat deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ja was
macht man am freitag dann lebt natürlich
eine neue folge der mannschaft ganz hoch
in der tat und ich habe wieder drei
richtig neisser commands am start und
ich würde mich freuen wenn du bist
mittendrin bleibt dann das video
bewertet weil ich am ende noch was von
bugs sage und dann fangen wir an mit
command nummer eins und nummer eins ist
von allgäu sido der ist irgendwie
spanier oder mexikaner oder so und zwar
handelt dieser command von einer
zeitbombe ja ihr habt richtig eine zeit
kommen und zwar gebe ich das hier im
chat also im command block 1
dann ganz normal drücke ich den schalter
hier oben wird etwas gespannt und
während das bauen das sieht jetzt mal
rechts im bild eingeblendet das ist
schon dauert so ein bisschen er gehe ich
mit ihr ins inventar und hole mir eine
glock benötige ich nämlich braucht dafür
nämlich keine glocken tnt einen amboss
muss ich mir noch holen und dann noch
einen bilderrahmen den habe ich jetzt
hier und jetzt muss ich da oh hallo
mister endermann und jetzt muss ich
nämlich hier den amboss einfach
hinsetzen packe die klopperei
normalerweise ist das hier auf englisch
und da steht dann klopft drin
dann müsste ich einfach in time komfort
setzen aber da ist auf deutsches mache
ich einfach weg und schreibe dort time
bomb glocken und das ist jetzt meine
zeitbombe nur wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise ein tnt hierhin setzte
dort einen rahmen drum platziere dann
kann ich an den rahmen einfach jedes
extreme reintun dann packe ich dort time
bomb lokal und ihr seht schon da zeit
komme wenn ich da drauf gucke time clock
und jetzt denkt man sich erstmal mit
diesen daten ist bisher nichts tolles
wenn ich jetzt allerdings mal richtig
drauf setze darauf klickt ihr seht ihr
schon news so 0 2 aber ich muss aus den
rahmen doch dicken 0 3 0 4 0 5 6 7 8 9
10 10 sekunden und wenn ich jetzt wieder
weiter rechts drauf drücke dann ist halt
so ne jetzt halt weiter hoch und wenn
ich jetzt links liegt ihr seht ihr schon
bereit click to be used disbon das als
wenn jetzt wieder rechts sich hier drauf
machen damit die ganze wieder ausschied
soll das funktioniert also jetzt habe
ich die interviews und jetzt wenn ich
jetzt mal wieder ein paar dabei steht
seit ich pack das jetzt bei 5 drücke
link linksklick und ich werde das jetzt
nicht diffusen seht ihr schon 200
explodiert einfach instant das ist quasi
auch schon command nummer eins der mir
so hart zugesetzt wurde von ihm von
alltron sieht die nur gesehen ist
irgendwie ein video von mir gelegt hatte
und
dann hab ich mal bin ich auf seinem
kanal gegangen und er hatte dort
eingecheckt command also den hier finde
ich sehr sehr cool mit der zeitbombe
kannst einfach irgendwo aufstellen was
ist dein kumpel beispielsweise im online
spiel modus soja der kommenden zehn
sekunden wieder so setzten eine
zeitbombe explodiert das tor her ich
kann es gar nicht gewesen sein ich stehe
doch hier hinter die oder irgendwie so
wer richtig cool kann man sich eventuell
wirklich etwas einfallen lassen
aber ich glaube nicht und mahnt nummer
zwei ist auch eine recht simple sache
also nummer drei wird halt extrem
umfangreich deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
1 und 2 kommen was das kleine sachen und
zwar ich nehme mir wieder den befehl
spox setzte den jetzt mal hier so schön
auf dem sand daneben einen hebel und die
wir dort diesen befehl ein und ihr seht
schon
ich muss den schalter drücken genau
jetzt freut sich hier so etwas kleines
auf und wir sehen jetzt jede mannschaft
sich hier so ein kleiner penis und anti
spam bei jappy gut 98 access folien
store
wenn ich mir jetzt nämlich mal hier
einen bogen wohl und sagen wir mal 64
pfeil und ich begebe mich jetzt in den
game mode 0 dann denkt man sich erstmal
was passiert denn jetzt ich kann jetzt
noch mal noch schießen allerdings wenn
ich versuche zur faust ballen seht ihr
der fall drop sich quasi mir direkt
wieder zu also er fällt quasi vor mir
nicht so halb auf dem boden das heißt
wenn ich ja ein sammel habe ich da
wieder allerdings allerdings wenn ich
ganz normal schiffe geht es halt klar so
ich kann ich halt so da hinten hin
schießen und so ich kann dann hätten sie
die schweine abschießen und so weiter
und so fort allerdings ich hab so ganz
schön getroffen dass er unfassbar was
guckst du so allerdings wenig halt
versuche zu baust werden also holt so
zeigt sich hier der fall formiert sich
einfach dass sie doch nie ganz cool aus
ich schieße einfach und man sieht quasi
keinen fall ankommen wenn ich allerdings
ganz normal bekommt der fall natürlich
hier das ist nämlich die anti spam
command wenn ich dann allerdings mir
denke ja ich möchte die zeit noch so ein
bisschen krasser machen kann ich einfach
ein game und 1 gehen kann auf den
commander oben zu greifen und hier die
zahl verändern da steht jetzt 1 wenn ich
dann beispielsweise auf 15 g oder so
dann ist es dementsprechend anders
das heißt wenn ich hier irgendwie
schieße da oder versuche vorstellen dann
gibt es dementsprechend halt klar
allerdings werde ich halt eine sehr
kleine zahl machte wie beispielsweise 1
dann seht ihr schon wenn ich versuche
post beim glaubt sich der fall quasi vor
mir selbst das ist ganz gut für so
bausch berlin sachen kann man ganz gut
auf in welchen servern anwenden et
cetera pp ist von juke 98 findet alle
commands videos und
rechtlichen urheber der command in der
beschreibung verlinkt ganz unten unter
meinem equipment und unter meinen
sozialen netzwerken wie twitter wo ihm
übrigens unbedingt folgen sollte wenn
ihr meine tweets sehen möchte denn nicht
gerade auf dem klo sitze dann machen wir
auch so weit mit 4,3 tory dass ich so
ein bisschen hier schnell mache aber es
ist gerade zwei uhr in der nacht und ich
muss um acht uhr morgens aufstehen weil
ich eine der 450 kilometer fahrt vor mir
habe ist wird der letzte command ist von
der hec gedacht schreibt jetzt in die
kommentare 11
minecraft genau von wem sonst hallo
immer wenn ich nämlich diesen command
hier ein gebe es dass wir ein sehr
langer koma das wickelt ganz kurz ich
drücke hier drauf es bond etwas und wäre
das ganze nicht erkläre ich euch mal
ganz gut was das ging schnell es ist
nämlich der lucky blogs kummer dh mit
diesen command können wir uns quasi so
lucky blogs minecraft machen dafür haben
jetzt diese maschine bekommen von
minecraft sind wir auch wieder hier im
chat kommt bei kam ein grafik klicken
hier draufklicken des atems rohgold
block in den korridoren zu get lucky
feiert rohgold ingrids in die fire to
get lucky blogs castro paper in der to
destroy die feier
das heißt wir benötigen auch noch gold
irgendwas das heißt man muss ein
bisschen interagieren und bekommt nicht
direkt alles in die wiege gelegt wird
gelegt was man hierfür benötigt das
heißt ich setze einen kessel in
schweizer den gold blog rein und ihr
seht schon
ich bekomme so ein feuer wenn ich jetzt
allerdings ein papier auf tour oder ein
paar vier reinschmeißen geht das feuer
wieder weg ich bekomme meine sachen
zurück das heißt ich lasse natürlich
stehen schmeißt einen goldbarren und
habe das feuer was mache ich mit diesem
feuer ich kann wenn ich da goldbarren
reinsch leute bekomme ich hab jetzt zehn
goldbarren reingeworfen das heißt ich
bekomme wieso habe ich nur 8 blocks geht
es ja auch egal jedenfalls muss sich der
goldbarren rhein werfen dann habe ich
ihr lucky blogs und wenn ich dir jetzt
hinsetzen seht ihr schon gesehen
eigentlich nahezu genauso aus wie die
lucky blogs die es normalerweise
wirklich gibt hinzugefügt werden auch
wenn ich die aok war
fakt ist was soll das denn da wäre ich
so safe bei gestorben
na ja wir haben hier mit gerade lucky
blogs mit einem command in minecraft
hinzugefügt übrigens auch sorry dass man
meine rechte gesichtshälfte so ein
bisschen so to face mäßig weil meine
softbox da ist in dem video was ihr
morgen seht da habe ich mein ganzes
equipment kaputt ja ich würde sagen wir
testen war noch ein paar andere lucky
blogs und zwar hier kommt ein wächter
raus das ist auch schon alles was kommt
hier aus einfachen tnt und redstone
fackeln ok in espoo racer und fackeln
machen ja so rotes licht nichts das
wusste ich gar nicht dann schauen wir
mal eben noch was hier raus kommt hier
kommt ganz einfach eine diamant
vertröstung auf seiner ist hier kommt
wieder tnt und rote fackeln und hier
kommt wieder eine an ihren wasser einmal
kommt dort einfach raus dann sitzen wir
kommen wir sagen weil wir machen noch
fünf lucky blogs hier eben
ich hätte ja auch mal lust am sonntag
ihr blog besser also ich hab zwei schafe
gesehen das liegt mega cool aus einfach
ich weiß nich hat überlegt doch mal zu
machen also hier kamen jetzt diese
sachen raus eine feuerkugel eine
verkehrt rum ist schicken ein slime
tower ganz viele verschiedene sachen
wenn ihr selbst mal testen wollt müsst
ihr und euch mit mottaki blogs an sich
nicht auskennt müsst ihr euch dafür
nicht extra eine blöde motto runter
laden sondern können das ganze jetzt
auch einfach mit einem command in
minecraft machen ich hoffe euch hat die
folge heute gefallen wenn es das getan
habe ich mich immer eine bewertung
freuen über ein abo würde ich mich auch
freuen aber meisten freue ich mich
darüber wenn ihr jetzt den handstand
machen würde und dabei gegen die wand
machen kann
[Musik]
keine ahnung alter jedenfalls war es das
jetzt man dieser episode was ich noch
sagen wollte bezüglich des buches ich
habe einen kommentar gesehen bisher den
ersten negativen kommentar bezüglich des
buches was ich habe jetzt schreibe über
minecraft sex und kommerz und so weiter
war dass jemand meinte bisher war kein
einziges buch von irgendwelchen youtuber
gut das wird eh du warst das nur wegen
dem geld und bla natürlich verdiene ich
daran etwas allerdings studiere ich
nebenbei und ich muss sagen man verdient
mit youtube nicht gerade wenig also das
heißt mach ich komme auch damit
irgendwie über die runden
ich bin nicht angewiesen auf geld oder
irgendwie sowas aber ich finde ein buch
ist etwas damit hinterlässt man etwas in
der welt und ich habe so viel bock
darauf weil ich noch nie so etwas
gemacht habe und wer es wir sind gerade
dabei
wir kommen gut voran es ist eine menge
arbeit ich ja haben heute auch wieder
vier stunden gemessen
aber es wird so
hammer freunde alle die das frage
antwort video von donnerstag eventuell
nicht gesehen haben da habe ich ja
dieses bild hier gezeigt so wird das
design nämlich circa von dem buch sein
das heißt da seht jetzt beispielsweise
die fakten cool dargestellt und da ihr
jetzt sogar noch dran seid alle zeige
ich euch noch eine zweite seite von dem
buch und zwar was könnte ich euch da mal
zeigen was gibt's dann ihr
beispielsweise also ich hab halt
wirklich nicht dass einer denkt dass ich
da irgend so ein ghostwriter habt ihr da
irgendwas macht alle texte sind von mir
so kontrolliert worden und ich habe die
allgemein noch aufgesagt und alles
mögliche haben wir das zusammen gemacht
wir sind alles durchgegangen also ich
hab dann natürlich einen kollegen vom
verlag mit dem ich das zusammen mache
weil viele man ja gern hintergründe
wissen möchten und so wird das
beispielsweise auch alles aussehen so
konnte als bekannt da bin ich hallo wir
haben sogar ein fotoshooting dafür
gemacht und so dieses shirt geht
übrigens kran kraft dar
danke martin bald stellt sehen weil ich
ganz schön heiß bin
seht ihr sogar noch eine seite ist das
nicht hammer komma da sind sich sogar im
auto mit max und patrick und so weiter
freunde mehr möchte ich gar nicht
verraten wir haben hier schon einige
seiten ausgedruckt wir dass es wird so
hammer ich freue mich so auf dieses buch
weil ich weiß es gibt youtuber die wagen
ja komm gib mir das geld schreibt gegen
buch mir egal will ich nicht das buch
soll geil werden und das wird geil
vertraut mit der bitte einfach an alle
die denken für takko oder so von mir aus
ich bringe buch mit zu einer
autogrammstunde mal oder so dann könnt
euch das ja gerne anschauen wenn es
nicht kaufen wollte ist es mir dann auch
egal
ich möchte es machen weil es mir spaß
macht und sonst würde ich es nicht
machen wir sehen uns in einer video
wieder teams